you get yelled at still because they
consider you the guy who injured alex
rodriguez right you were doing a
baseball unbelievable a-rod is talking
to you on the sidelines right yeah so i
walk out i'm with my sister's son jack
and i walk out of the dugout and i'm
walking down and alex who's become a
good friend of mine is standing there at
third base while they're taking batting
practice and he looks over to me goes
hey joe and i said hey alex
and i keep walking he goes hey joe
is that your boy he's starting to say is
that your boy
boy
and and lance berkman who was playing
for the yankees at the time hits a
rocket
it crunches him right under his knee oh
man and he goes
i mean like running out one legged into
center field is rolling around in the
grass in center field grabbing his leg
and my sister son jack who's got this
raspy voice is like i don't think that's
good
and i go up to the booth i'm i'm
standing down there and i'm like oh my
god i hope nobody saw me you know
talking to him right and eventually
one of the players said oh i know how he
got hurt he was talking to that that fox
guy what's a buck what's his name and
then then the horde of media guys turn
on me they're like what happened i said
they just walked out on the field he
turned his head to say hi and he got
whacked i mean i don't know what else to
do so people used to blame you for that
it was the cover it was the back cover
of the daily news oh my god it said what
the buck
it was it was a game against the red sox
they took him out of the lineup he
didn't play the next night and yankee
fans have never forgiven you that's
right they hate me i know we had we we
interviewed like yankee fans they were
like [ __ ] joe yeah yeah yeah he [ __ ]
killed him
yeah i mean all i did was exist and i
got motherfucked for that yeah you
really did yeah but that's you know
it's
yankee fans it's crazy yankee fans
believe
that i don't like the yankees which
if you know anything about television
and ratings if there's one team red sox
two if there's one team cubs you want
these teams in the postseason because
you're going to get bigger you're going
to get bigger ratings where where do you
want to be in the postseason they don't
blame you for the ratings if a super
bowl's low or something they usually
blame the well it was two shitty teams
or something like that competitive i
mean yeah some of that stuff you're just
kind of a victim of whatever game you
get yeah but yeah it's it's it's so
maddening because you they're like you
hate the yankees i've been chased out of
a bar
in boston with two guys going hey is
that joe buck and they i was walking
into the hotel they were running toward
me about to kick my ass and i had to
walk
at a fast i wouldn't run i wouldn't give
them that side people are [ __ ] yeah
it's unbelievable i mean it's
unbelievable very seriously